[Music]
this land
this family
it's always been kind of like a dream to
me
i don't know part of me i guess
figured one dad wake up
i'm looking for the abbott ranch yeah
we're not a tourist ranch come on i was
looking at camp only a few days autumn
royal
glad to finally meet you
why are you here you see that i've been
drawing it for years and now i see it
all over the place here
you stay away from her you understand
and that goes for everyone
i want that land
why
there's something out there
what is this royal
i don't know what it is this will just
be our
i
little
secret
as patrick because of what you west best
my west
you tell me
something's happening here something
bigger than you and me and the world's
been waiting for something like this
[Music]
you ever wonder if the world's not what
you think it is
no law
no order
just chaos all the way down
hello something
something is happening
just call me angel of the morning
please
can you quit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you